[Música]
Sim, agora sim. Agora tá com som. É que
esse microfone aqui, pessoal, só
encostar nele, ele desliga. Quer ver? Ó,
ligou. Ligou. É por isso. Vamos lá.
Sejam muito bem-vindos, Alice Vogel,
Enild.
Ainda bem que vocês avisaram porque
demoraram para entrar, por isso que eu
não tava percebendo. Beleza. E como é
que tá o som agora? Tá bom?
Me digam se o som tá bom.
Vou esperar vocês me darem o feedback
que eu tô usando o microfone profissa
aqui que eu devia estar usando mais.
Bem, voltando ao começo, porque ninguém
me escutou,
vamos bater um papo sobre um assunto que
tá bombando aí nas notícias de saúde.
Vai na mesma linha daquela reportagem do
Fantástico que passou no último domingo,
que foi muito polêmica e eu não sei se
vocês viram o meu vídeo resposta que eu
postei no Instagram, que também vai sair
no YouTube amanhã.
Então, imagina só, você tá tomando a
vitamina B6, achando que tá indo muito
bem, fazendo muito bem pra saúde, de
repente aparece manchetes da Austrália e
também processos judiciais por danos
nervosos causados por essa vitamina. E
como é que pode uma vitamina essencial
pra vida causar tanto estrago assim?
Então, Alice, dá uma olhadinha no
Instagram, então se você quiser, amanhã
já vai sair no YouTube também, tá?
Então vem comigo, vou contar essa
história para você direitinho, explicar
como é que uma vitamina, no caso da B6,
pode fazer mal sim a saúde.
E vocês sabem, né, a diferença entre
remédio e veneno é a dose. Então,
exemplo muito comum, sabe quando você tá
lá na cozinha preparando o almoço e
precisa de sal? O sal essencial paraa
saúde, o cloreto de sódio essencial,
você precisa de sódio, precisa de
cloreto, mas se você despejar
o saleiro inteiro na panela, vai ser um
desastre. Então a vitamina B6 é mais ou
menos assim também. Ela é fundamental
pro corpo. Sem ela, a gente literalmente
não funciona direito. O nosso cérebro
precisa para produzir serotonina,
que é o neurotransmissor, um dos
neurotransmissores da felicidade, né,
junto com a dopamina.
E também precisamos da B6, além de da
própria dopamina, da serotonina, também
o gaba. Então, toda essa turma de
neurotransmissores importantes para
manter o nosso humor equilibrado e o
nosso sistema nervoso funcionando
direitinho. Então, vou te contar uma
história interessante.
A vitamina B6 não é uma coisa só, ela é
uma família com três primos. Temos a
piridoxina, que é a forma mais comum que
você vai encontrar nos suplementos
baratos. Tem o piridoxal c fosfato, que
eu sempre falo é a forma fosfatada, é a
forma metilada
e é então a mais recomendada. Tem a
peridoxamina,
qual é o pulo do gato aqui? Para
funcionar de verdade no nosso corpo,
todas essas formas precisam ser
convertidas
na forma P5P, OK? Pridoxal, cinco
fosfato, que é a versão tubinada, a
versão ativa que o corpo vai utilizar de
forma direta, sem precisar de conversão
no fígado. E aí que entra o perigo.
Quando a gente toma doses cavalares de
piridoxina, tipo 200, 300, até 500 mg
por dia, tô falando de piridoxina, tá?
Isso se você fizer então doses altas
por vários dias, meses a fio, o fígado
fica sobrecarregado tentando converter
tudo isso. É como se você pedisse pro
seu liquidificador processar pedras o
dia inteiro, ele vai pifar, né,
obviamente. Então o que acontece é que a
piroxina não convertida, então a forma
mais barata da vitamina B6 em doses
altas por muitos dias ou semanas começa
a se acumular e ela pode agir como um
antagonista bloqueando os caminhos onde
a vitamina B6 deveria funcionar. É tipo
colocar chiclete na fechadura. Ao invés
de abrir a porta você trava tudo. Então
lá na Austrália teve um caso de uma
médica, Dra. Mary Bucannon, que
desenvolveu a fraqueza muscular
progressiva e também neuropatia
periférica. E sabe o que que é isso? É
quando os nervos das extremidades
começam a falhar. Então ela contou que
não conseguia andar nem 100 m porque se
tornou um sacrifício danado. E olha que
interessante, ela tava tomando a
vitamina B6, sem saber tava escondido em
comprimidos de magnésio que ela comprou
na farmácia. E depois de parar um ano de
usar o produto, ela tava ainda se
recuperando. Então veja que estrago fez
na saúde dela uma dose elevada de mais
de B6 na forma de
piridoxamina, né, ou na forma de
piridoxina, ou seja, uma forma não
metilada.
Então, será que você então precisa jogar
fora os suplementos que tem B6? Não, a
questão toda é o contexto.
Quando a gente trabalha no contexto da
medicina integrativa funcional,
a gente nunca, nunca mesmo usa nutriente
de maneira isolada, né? Vocês nunca vão
ver o prescrevendo só vitamina D ou só
vitamina K2 ou só B1, B2, B3. a gente
usa nutrientes em conjunto,
é um trabalho em equipe. Então, a
vitamina B6 ela precisa de vários
parceiros, do magnésio, da B2, da B12,
né? A gente com balamina, do do ácido
fólico folato, metiofolato e do zinco. É
como se fosse um time de futebol e não
adianta ter só atacante se o resto do
time não tá jogando junto. E tem mais,
obviamente cada pessoa é única. A Medina
tem que ser o mais personalizada
possível.
Tem gente que por questões genéticas não
consegue converter direito a perdoxina
em peridoxal cinco fosfato. E seria como
ter um carro flexa bem o álcool. Você
precisaria usar gasolina para esse carro
supostamente flex funcionar. Por isso
que hoje em dia muitos profissionais já
preferem prescrever direto. No meu caso,
a forma ativa, o peridoxal cinco
fosfato. É mais caro, mas vale a pena. é
mais seguro e mais eficiente.
Bem, é importante vocês saberem que a
vitamina B6 está em tudo quanto é lugar
hoje em dia, em vários tipos de
suplementos,
tá escondido em vários lugares. Aí tem
bebida energética, tem cereal matinal
fortificado. Eu tô falando da forma da
B6 mais barata, né, que pode dar
potencialmente problemas. Pode estar em
shake para emagrecer, pode estar em
multivitamínico. Então, se você tá
tomando várias coisas ao mesmo tempo e
não checou direito osótulo, você pode
estar ingerindo B6 em excesso.
É como se fosse açúcar escondido nos
alimentos processados, tá em todo lugar.
Então, o governo australiano tá tão
preocupado com isso que agora existe
rótulo de aviso em produtos com mais de
10 mg de B6 por dia. Então, tão querendo
tornar produtos com 50 a 200 mg
disponíveis só com supervisão
farmacêutica.
E essa preocupação é bastante plausível,
entendo ela. Mas eu também acho que
estão jogando bebê fora junto com a do
banho, porque quando você usa B6 de
forma correta, adequada, com
acompanhamento profissional, a vitamina
B6 em doses terapêuticas pode ser um
santo remédio para várias situações.
Por exemplo, mulheres que têm TPM grave
ou severa, podem se beneficiar com doses
mais altas, né, do peridoxal
ciclofosfato,
mas sempre com o magnésio junto. Então,
100 a 200 mg de período oxal ciclo
fosfato com magnésio e pro período
limitado. Pessoas que têm, por exemplo,
síndrome do túnem
melhorar muito. E o segredo tá em três
palavrinhas: contexto, sinergia e
monitoramento.
Contexto porque você precisa entender o
paciente como um todo, como é que tá a
dieta, o nível de estresse, a exposição
a toxinas, o funcionamento do fígado e
sinergia, porque a vitamina B6 sozinha é
como tentar fazer feijoada só com o
feijão, né? não vai dar certo. E
monitoramento porque você precisa
acompanhar, ver se tá funcionando, se
apareceu algum sintoma estranho.
Eliseu, não tem perguntas no documento.
Eu vou olhar de novo, tá?
Não sei se vocês não entendi também
porque o documento tá vazio. Eu deixei
aí a
o link lá fixado, mas
não sei o que que houve.
Bem, vamos continuar aqui.
Dicas práticas, né? Um manual para
vocês. Se você tá tomando vitamina B6
e começou a sentir forro emigamento nas
mãos, nos pés, dificuldade para andar,
sensibilidade exagerada, luz
ou nusas persistentes, para tudo procura
orientação médica. Então, boa notícia é
que na maioria dos casos, quando você
para de tomar, os sintomas melhoram, mas
quanto mais tempo você demorar para
perceber, mais difícil pode ser
recuperação completa. Veja que aquela
doutora ficou mais de um ano sem tomar,
ainda não tá recuperada.
Então, se você for tomar B6, tome o
peridoxal ciclo fosfato.
Então, é muito mais interessante se
utilizar a forma mais segura. É como
escolher entre pegar o metrô direto pro
seu destino ou fazer 15 baldeiações, né?
Você vai chegar da mesma maneira no
destino, mas um jeito é muito mais
eficiente e seguro. E sempre, sempre
mesmo combine com o magnésio. Magnésio é
tipo melhor amigo da ABC. Eles trabalham
juntos em mais de 300 reações no corpo,
sem magnésio adequado. A B6 não vão
funcionar direito, ainda pode causar
problemas. E tem uma coisa importante,
seus hormônios influenciam muito como o
seu corpo usa a vitamina B6.
Mulheres tomando anticoncepcional, por
exemplo, precisam de mais B6 porque o
estrogênio compete.
Então, pessoas com hipotiroidismo também
podem precisar de doses maiores e quem
toma corticovide regularmente também tem
necessidade aumentada, então tá tudo
interligado. O corpo humano é uma
sinfonia, não dá para tocar só uma nota
e esperar que saia a música bonita.
No final das contas, o que eu quero que
vocês levem para casa nossas conversa é
o seguinte: vitamina B6 é segura e
benéfica quando usada com inteligência
da forma correta. Então os processos que
acontecem na Austrália não são sobre a
vitamina C ruim, são sobre o uso
inadequado na forma inadequada, sem
orientação e doses exageradas e por
tempo prolongado demais e também sem os
cofatores necessários. É como dirigir,
né? O carro não é perigoso, mas se você
dirigir a 200 km/h na contramão e sem
cinto de segurança, tudo vai ser muito
mais complicado.
Então a mensagem final, respeitem os
nutrientes, usem com sabedoria, sempre
comento médico, profissional ou
nutricionista.
E quando for além da dose nutricional
básica, aí que tá essencial o
acompanhamento médico. E prestem atenção
nos sinais do corpo. E na medicina
funcional a gente não trata sintomas
isolados, a gente cuida da pessoa
inteira. É olhar pra floresta, não só
pra árvore. É entender que tudo no corpo
tá conectado e que saúde e verdade vem
de equilíbrio e não de exagero. Beleza?
Bem, gente, eu vou falar de um outro
artigo, OK? E depois nós vamos às
perguntas, tá? As perguntas ao vivo, que
eu já vi que o Eliseu deixou algumas
aqui.
Ã, vamos falar um pouquinho sobre
Covid-19, fertilidade masculina. Esse
foi um tema que eu abordei ano passado
em um simpósio online, que eu falei a
convite Dra. Maria Emília na Médicos
pela Vida. Ela me chamou para falar da
situação do impacto do COVID-19 na
fetilidade, mas temos novas informações,
então decidi falar desse assunto com
vocês também.
Então, sabemos que a COVID é muito mais
que uma gripe, é muito mais do que uma
doença que afeta o sistema respiratório,
é muito mais uma doença do que uma
doença que afeta pulmão, vias aéreas.
Ela chega até lugares que a gente
inicialmente nem imaginava. E um desses
lugares é o testículo, né, e também a
função de produção de espermatozoides.
Então, COVID, ela deve estar sabotando
silenciosamente a fetilidade masculina e
muita gente não se deu conta disso.
Vamos falar aqui de uma situação de um
personagem chamado João que teve COVID
em 2023. teve sintomas leves, ficou em
casa, nada demais, não precisou de
hospital, de tumbação, graças a Deus,
tomou lá os seus chazinhos e a vida que
segue. Dois anos depois, ele e a esposa
decidiram aumentar a família. Tentaram,
tentaram e nada. Foram procurar ajuda
médica e o espermograma vem com uma
surpresa nada agradável. a contagemóides
lá embaixo, a motilidade também
comprometida
e um marcador que é feito aí em clínicas
de fertilização, que não é um
espermograma comum, que é um índice de
fragmentação DNA. Esse parâmetro também
tava bem aumentado.
E aí o médico da clínica de efetividade
resolveu perguntar: "Você já teve
COVID?" E olha que interessante, um
estudo bem recente publicado esse ano na
Scientific Reportou
mais de 600 homens na China. E sabe o
que foi descoberto? Que 83% dos que
tiveram COVID apresentaram pior a
significativa na qualidade do esperma. E
isso não é pouca coisa, né? 83%
dos chineses desse estudo tiveram piora
da qualidade do esperma.
A contagem esmatozoides cai em média
12%, o que significa perder uns 20
milhões de espatozoides por amostra. É
como se fosse um batalhão inteiro que
sumisse do mapa. E a uma utilidade que a
capacidade dos esmatozoóides de nadar
com vigor caiu 17% no total.
E impressionantes, 37% daqueles
espumatozóides mais rápidos, que é o
grau A de movimentação,
que seriam os atletas olímpicos, né,
digamos assim, da fertilização.
Teve essa queda então de 37% do grau A e
17% no geral em termos de motilidade.
Mas vamos lá, o que que podemos fazer a
respeito, tá?
Aqui no Brasil, vários estudos
confirmaram que o vírus pode causar
então a inflamação no epidídmo, que
seria a causa dessa situação aí de queda
de fertilidade. Então e pedido, aquela
estrutura onde esmatozoóides ficam
armazenados e ganham a capacidade de
movimento. É uma estrutura que fica no
polo superior ali do testículo.
Então,
numa analogia é como se fosse um
vestiário onde os jogadores se preparam
antes de entrar em campo. Então, é lá
que eles se concentram para depois serem
eliminados pela ejaculação. OK?
Então sabemos que essa epididmite
causada pelo vírus, ela provoca essa
queda de fertilidade por causa da
inflamação do epidídio.
Então, teve uma coisa que os pisadores
descobriram que é muito relevante. O tal
do estresse oxidativo, que é quando o
nosso corpo produz muitos radicais
livres, que são as moléculas bagunceiras
que danificam as células, aumentou mais
de 100% desse estresse oidativo nos
homens com COVID. É como se o corpo
tivasse uma fábrica descontrolada de
ferrugem celular. E adivinem quem sofre
com isso? Exatamente. Os espatozóides
são células super sensíveis e delicadas.
Agora vem a parte boa da história, a
parte que eu gosto de contar. Então,
porque a medicina profissional não fica
só olhando o problema, a gente vai atrás
da solução. E sabe o que nós
descobrimos? Que podemos virar esse jogo
usando a natureza a nosso favor. Aí que
entra os antioxidantes naturais. Então
vamos começar falando pelo zinco, esse
mineral que vocês bem conhecem e que
funciona como um personal training
dosides.
Estudos mostram que homens que t baixo
zinco no organismo tem testosterona
também baixa. Então é uma coisa
importante homem com testosterona baixa
checar os níveis de zinco. Mas não é só
isso. Ele afeta também osóides que ficam
preguiçosos. Nossa suplementação de 20 a
100 mg de zinco por dia pode aumentar de
forma significativa a contagem e
motilidade. E onde se encontra zinco de
forma natural? Vocês devem saber, mas
não custa mencionar. Nas ostras, né? Por
isso que elas têm a fama de afrodisíaca,
nas carnes vermelhas, nas sementes de
abóbora e no feijão também do dia a dia.
A vitamina C também importante, né? Um
antioxidante aí clássico, todos
conhecem.
Não é só bom paraa gripe, também é uma
aliada poderosa a fertilidade. Então,
olha que interessante, a vitamina C tem
uma concentração 10 vezes maior no
líquido seminal do que no sangue. É o
corpo precisando utilizar a vitamina C
de maneira direcionada para melhorar a
fetilidade. Então, é importante repor a
vitamina C, 2 g por dia, para quem tem
esse problema. pode aumentar a
motilidade em até 40% e reduzir
osmatozoides
deformados.
A comquenz também é top para isso.
Também um grande antioxidante,
funciona como se fosse uma bateria, né,
pros espermatozóides.
E isso acontece então quando você repõe
com enzima Q10, melhora a fertilidade.
200 a 400 mg por dia, podem melhorar
tanto a motilidade quanto a
concentração. E o mais legal é que
trabalha direto nas mitocôndrias
dos espermatozóides.
O selênio mineral também que vocês bem
conhecem, a gente encontra na castanha
do Brasil, na castanha do Pará e que tem
ação antioxidante muito importante
também. É fundamental paraa morfologia
dosides
e é ele que ajuda a manter a estrutura
dosides sem defeitos.
Ele garante que os motozó que funciona
como se fosse um foguete, né, tem esse
formato aerodinâmico,
que ele chegue ao seu destino.
E duas castanhas do Pará geralmente
afonecem 200 microg por dia, que seria o
suficiente desse mineral. A vitamina D
todos conhecem também, é fundamental
paraa produção de testosterona. Homens
com deficiência de vitamina D tem 30%
menos desse hormônio e 15 minutinhos de
sol por dia sem protetor solar já ajudam
muito a produzir a nossa vitamina D.
OK? Temos também a L carnitina, outro
nutriente que merece bastante destaque.
Ela funciona como premium
prosmatozóides,
dá energia para eles poderem nadarem com
força total. Então, estudos mostram que
2 a 3 g por dia pode melhorar
significativamente a motilidade. Então,
alcarntina pode ser usado como
suplemento, mas é encontrado também nas
carnes vermelhas.
Estilo de vida, como vocês sabem,
redução do álcool é bem importante, não
quer dizer que você vai eliminar
totalmente a cervejinha do final de
semana, mas o excesso de álcool é um
verdadeiro assassino dos
espermatozóides.
Diminui o estrogênio, aumenta o
estrogênio, desculpa, diminui a
testosterona, aumenta o estrogênio, como
vocês sabem, e deixa os prometoides
tontos, vamos dizer assim, né?
Cigarro tem que cessar totalmente porque
os produtos químicos desse elemento
danificam o DNA dosides, diminuem a
contagem e pior a motilidade. OK? Então,
quer ser pai, o cigarro tem que ir
embora. E o estresse, o grande vilão
silencioso da fertilidade moderna.
Quando estamos estressados, o corpo
docortisol que compete com a
testosterona, é como se o corpo
dissesse: "Caro, você tá fugindo de
leão, não é hora de pensar a
reprodução". Então, para combater isso,
meditação, exercício, hobbies, qualquer
coisa que reduza o estresse, vale ouro
para a fertilidade.
A atividade física não precisa nem
falar, é muito importante também,
logicamente que não em excesso, porque
aumenta a testosterona, melhora a
circulação e reduz o estresse. Cuidado
com excesso, porque também não é bom.
E óbvio, não precisa nem dizer para
vocês que quem toma bomba, tomar
anabolizante, vai ter problemas sérios
de fertilidade. Então é importante a ver
o equilíbrio. E a alimentação
fundamental de atra mediterrânea, riqu
em peixes, azeite, vegetais,
frutosinoses, é um prato cheio para a
fertilidade. Os ômega-3 dos peixes
gordurosos, como salmão e sardinha são
essenciais para membrana espatozoides.
Então, sem um brân saudável, o
espatozoide não consegue penetrar no
óvulo. É como tentrarem, é como tentar
entrar em casa com a chave torta.
E a temperatura dos testículos é
importante manter elas na temperatura
adequada. Então, fica em torno de 2º
mais frio do que a temperatura corporal.
Então, para isso acontecer precisa ter
alguns cuidados, deixar o notebook longe
do colo, evitar banho muito quente,
salta em excesso e evitar roupa íntima
apertada, que isso pode prejudicar a
produção de espermatozoides. E é por
isso que eles vivem nessa bolsa, no
escroto, por conta de necessitar
temperatura um pouco mais baixa.
Então, em relação ao nosso amigo João,
que nós falamos lá no começo, depois de
entender toda essa história, ele começou
um protocolo de recuperação,
suplementação com antioxidantes, mudança
de tiro de vida, alimentação balanceada
e houve essa renovação do estoque
espatozoides, que nos homens acontece a
cada 70 ou 90 dias. Então, em 3 meses,
ele já teve uma melhora importante no
seu espermograma.
Então, estudos mostram que após três a
se meses de tratamento adequado, a
maioria dos homens que tiveram COVID
consegue recuperar qualidade esemática.
Não é milagre, sim aplicar a ciência com
inteligência. Então, nosso corpo humano
tem grande capacidade de recuperação, de
resiliência, que devemos então dar as
condições para ele poder trabalhar.
E tem que ter paciência, obviamente, né?
Alguns casos de fertilidade pode demorar
vários meses para melhorar. Cada corpo
responde de um jeito, então o importante
é não desistir e fazer o acompanhamento
bem direitinho.
Então, se vocês conhecem alguém da
família, estão com dificuldade em
engravidar, peçam pro homem fazer esse
femmograma, porque metade dos casos de
fertilidade conjugal tem participação
masculina. Metade. Então, pode ser só o
homem ou o homem e a mulher, mas o homem
participa em metade dos casos.
É um exame chato de fazer, um exame meio
envergonhado, né, mas importante para
esses casos aí. E especialmente se esse
homem teve COVID, aí tem que fazer esse
pograma com mais importância ainda.
Ã, então tem uma polêmica, tá? Eu até
agora não consegui achar a literatura
que provasse que as picadinhas tiveram
efeito negativo na fertilidade. A gente
desconfia muito desse assunto, mas
quando eu fiz a última
pesquisa, o último levantamento, eu não
achei provas ou sugestões de que as
picadinhas poderiam ser prejudiciais,
apesar de eu pensar seriamente que isso
é bem provável.
Talvez esses estudos não foram
publicados por pressões aí de da
indústria, né?
Então, só para vocês saberem, todos
esses antioxidantes que nós mencionamos,
vocês sabem que eles não só funcionam
para fertilidade,
a mudança de estilo de vida também não
funciona só para fertilidade. Tudo isso
vai melhorar a qualidade de vida, vai
dar mais energia, mais desempenho, mais
humor e também libido muito melhor, tá?
Então tem vários aí benefícios extras
além da fertilidade.
Então pessoal, alertem a seus entes
queridos aí que estão na faixa
reprodutiva, filhos, netos, casais aí
que possam estar com dificuldade para
ficarem atentos em relação a isso. com
conhecimento, suplementação inteligente
e mudança estilo de vida, é totalmente
possível recuperar e melhorar a
qualidade do espatozoides.
E isso é um fato muito preocupante,
porque nós sabemos que a houve uma queda
significativa da fetidade masculina
desde os anos 70, isso antes do Covid e
deve estar piorando cada vez mais isso
por conta dos chestrógenos,
por conta aí do estilo de vida ruim, da
intoxicação ambiental. Então é muito
importante a gente conscientizar nossos
amigos e familiares quanto essa questão
tão fundamental.
Então vamos às perguntas. Deixa eu só
baixar a mesa que eu cansei de ficar em
pé já.
[Música]
Prontinho. Vamos ver ajustar aqui o
monitor.
Umas perguntas do Eliseu. Vamos lá.
Senhora de 35 anos, problema de visão.
Senhora, de 35 anos, problemas de visão
devido à diabetes. Recentemente começou
a apresentar problemas de audição.
Ozonoterapia pode ajudar na audição?
Olha, ajudaria dizer, mas seria
totalmente uma coisa terciária, não
diria nem secundária, tá? Aí seria muito
mais o controle do diabetes,
né? Porque
você precisa desbloquear
a não sei porque que telefone tem
conversar comigo agora.
Então eu faria o controle de diabetes e
o zônio entraria com uma terapia
totalmente adjuvante, tá? Não vejo
ozônio como nada revolucionário nesse
caso aí, não, tá?
Tem que tratar essa neuropatia, porque
esse ouvido ruim
e a visão ruim tá totalmente relacionado
aí ao descontrole do diabetes.
Ao tomar banho quente antes de dormir,
quanto tempo a pessoa tem que tomar
banho frio
pro corpo produzir melatonina?
Não sei. Elu nunca ouvi falar nessa
história de choque térmico, aumenta a
melatonina. Teria que olhar isso.
Consumir 200 g de mestida e excesso. 200
g é bastante coisa, né?
Mas eu acredito que não vai fazer nenhum
mal, não, tá? Só vai fazer mal pro
bolso, né? Porque no Brasil estilo meio
caro. A frase: você não tem que comer o
que gosta assim que é importante faz
sentido? Faz, né? É o que a gente fala
todo dia aqui, né? Tem um monte de
alimento gostoso aí que faz mal pra
saúde.
Alguém mais quer fazer perguntas,
pessoal?
Temos a Alice Bogel, a Inild, Macedo, o
Eliseu.
Não tô vendo mais ninguém aqui porque eu
só consigo ver quem está se
manifestando, tá?
Porque quando é live fechada eu não
consigo ver quantas pessoas estão
assistindo ao vivo.
Consumir cinco metilos por dia, adianta
alguma coisa? Com certeza adianta,
Eliseu. Eh, se fizer todo dia vai
adiantar muito.
Se eu atendo esse perfil de paciente,
atendo com certeza. Atendo um monte de
idoso aqui na clínica. Muitos com défic
cognitivo.
Bem, vocês assistiram o vídeo resposta
que eu fiz em relação à reportagem do
Fantástico. Se não assistiram, vai estar
lá no canal amanhã. Aliás, vocês podem
assistir porque vocês são do grupo, são
dos apoiadores. Então o vídeo já está
publicado para quem é apoiador, OK?
Então, é, eh, essa reportagem bastante
impacto, apesar de que o Fantástico cada
vez menos tá relevante. Então, no
Instagram lá teve bastante visualização.
Mais perguntas, pessoal. Essa história
da melatonina, eles serviço onde que
choque térmico vai aumentar melatonina?
Nunca ou vi falar nisso.
Ver se eu faço uma pesquisa rápida sobre
isso aqui agora.
Mm.
Bem, aqui tá dizendo que a melatonina tá
associada à regulação do balanço
térmico, mas não há evidência clara de
que o choque térmico aumente a
melatonina endógena no organismo.
Então, melatonina favorece a perda de
calor pela pele e reduz o ponto de
ajuste térmico no cérebro, ajudando a
diminuir a temperatura corporal à noite,
o que está ligado à indução do sono.
Eu não sei onde é que você viu isso, que
choque térmico dava aumento de
melatonina, né?
Qual o link para ver? Vamos lá, então.
Deixa eu abrir aqui.
Tá lá no canal, né? Mas se é só procurar
lá, mas vamos pegar o link aqui.
Ã, ah, já acabou de ser lançado agora
pro pessoal em em geral aqui,
ó. Ó, vamos gerar o link compartilhável.
Vou colocar aqui.
Pronto,
coloquei aqui, ó.
Tá, colocar lá no grupo também. Pera aí.
Ah, inclusive esse link já foi no grupo,
né? Porque quando o vídeo é lançado,
vocês já recebem o,
né, o o link.
Pronto.
Mais perguntas, pessoal.
Deixa eu ver como é que tão,
como é que está sendo o impacto desse
vídeo que saiu tem 46 minutos.
Sei. É, o canal nunca mais vai voltar a
ser como antes, né? Antes um vídeo que a
mal era 30.000 1000 visualizações em uma
semana e um vídeo bom era 200, um vídeo
excepcional era 500, né? 1000. Agora eu
tenho que me contentar com 1000
visualizações, 2000, 3.000, né?
Olha, se tem ideia, eh um vídeo que deu
40.000 visualizações,
já tem algumas semanas já.
Foi do Protein Spike. Deve ter umas três
semanas aí que saiu.
Aí, ó. Tá vendo? Saiu dia 26 de junho.
Não tem mais tempo, ó. Deu 48.000
visualizações esse vídeo, mas saiu dia
26 de junho. Já tem o quê? Julho e
agosto tem mais de dois meses, né? Então
é é a nova realidade do canal. ou aceita
ou sai do YouTube.
Infelizmente eu não falo aquilo que o
YouTube quer que seja dito, né? E
antigamente o YouTube,
quando o algoritmo dele estava menos
viciado, me ajudava mais. Agora o
algoritmo me atrapalha, né? Eu acho que
eu vou ter que começar a fazer tomar
banho de Nutella para poder
e não adianta, não vou conseguir fazer
isso. Vou consegu tomar banho de Nutella
para poder aparecer no YouTube.
Bem, pessoal, est meio caladinhos aqui.
Ninguém mais tá falando nada.
Eu acho que eu vou encerrar
aqui. O Ivan tá se manifestando.
Obrigado, Ivan. Você quase não fala, né?
Usei acetilcistina 90 dias.
Pode causar alergia de pele como eu
estou enfrentando.
Alergia de pele não é muito difícil.
Pode ser algum excipiente, né? Alguma
coisa da cápsula causando alergia em
você. Mas geralmente na não dá alergia
porque é aminoácido, né? Que o seu corpo
precisa.
E assim, o que dá vermelhão na pele, que
o pessoal confunde muito com alergia, é
o
aacina, né? Vitamina B3. Agora, na que
eu saiba não provoca
alergia na pele, não. Tá. Tá tomando o
NAC isoladamente ou tá associado a
alguma outra coisa?
Boa noite, Dr. Aninha. Seja muito
bem-vinda à live.
É, aqui tá dizendo que é raro. Eu nunca
vi, eu nunca vi eh não
poderia acontecer opções nucutâneas,
coceira, opticária, edema, broncoasmo.
Então pare de utilizar, viu? O NAC,
pode ser que seja uma coincidência
também, né?
Bem, eu não me lembro de ter visto
alguma reação alérgica na minha
carreira, mas que tá dizendo que é
possível. Sim. Tá.
Ã, sintomas, coceira nas nádegas, mas só
nas nádegas, Iva, geralmente alergia é
mais extenso no corpo, né? Não pegar só
nádega.
Tô na Apola tá sugerindo ver a marca do
NAC. Eu passei um tempo com rinite,
sinusite bem forte,
tá? Mas foi antes de tomar o NAC, né?
Então você tomou na para melhorar rinite
sinusite, não é isso?
Me parece que é isso, né?
Tá. Então é possível ser alergia. A
melhor coisa que você faz é interromper
o uso do NAC eh por um tempo e reavalia,
tá?
Se passar totalmente sintomas, é porque
era o NAC mesmo.
E aí, digamos, você ficou uma semana sem
tomar e toma um pouquinho de na outra
semana, depois de s dias sem tomar. Se
sentir a coceira de novo, aí você
confirma que é o NAC mesmo que tá te
dando problema.
OK. Beleza. Entendeu, Ivan, as
explicações?
Ficou alguma dúvida?
Eu
tenho muita cocela no nariz, por
exemplo, mas não é reação alérgica não.
Eu sou meio estaminérgico, tenho um
pouquinho de estamina em acesso no meu
corpo.
Beleza?
Bem, pessoal, acho que eu vou encerrar,
então, a não ser que vocês tenham alguma
pergunta mais ou que vocês têm algum
outra tipo de
observação aí.
Sim, essa é a dose padrão, né? Você pode
tomar uma ou duas vezes ao dia,
tá? Vou da Eurofarma, que é uma empresa
que eu não tenho nada contra, não tenho
nenhum tipo de informação
que seja
ruim sobre essa empresa, né? é uma
empresa nacional que geralmente trabalha
com genéricos, mas nunca ouvi nenhuma
informação que seja
detratora da empresa.
De nada, Enild. Eu que agradeço. Sim,
você poderia tomar até duas vezes ao
dia, mas como você teve reação alérgica,
não faça. Então,
bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês, um grande abraço e
até a semana que vem.